- Learning.
- Learn as much as you can.
- Learn something.
- Learn it all.
- Learning.
- Learn.
- Hello, Believe Nation.
Today I'm going to give
you some extra motivation
for how you can keep learning.
And as always, as people
are talking to say something
that really resonates
with you, please leave it
in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy!
(inspirational music)
- So you went to Harvard
and you dropped out.
Have you ever thought how
your life could be better off
if you had gotten your Harvard degree?
- Well I'm a weird dropout
because I take college
courses all the time, I love
learning company courses
and things, so I love being a student
and there were smart people
around and they fed you
and they gave you these
nice grades that made you
feel smart, so I feel it was
unfortunate that I didn't
get to stay there, but I don't
think I missed any knowledge
because whatever I needed to learn,
I was still in a learning mode.
- If you could talk to your younger self,
knowing what you know, and
those days when you thought,
"Maybe it's not going to happen."
What would you tell yourself?
- Play it cool.
I'd say, I'd say, "Play
it cool and learn as much
"as you can because everything
you learn, you're going to need.
"You won't have enough time to learn.
"Everything is an education."
- You should learn something
from each and every single
round you play in, every
single round you should learn
something, whether it's one
thing, it might be 20 things.
Learn something for each and every round.
And I've done that, every
round that I've played,
I've come back home,
I've critiqued my round,
I've looked at it from the
mental and mechanical side,
what went wrong, what went right,
and apply it to the next day.
- What is it that makes
you real special champion?
- Well, I just, I never,
well for one, I never quit
and never stopped skating, I
mean, I never took a hiatus
of, say, five years and came
like, "This seems hot now"
and then came back into it.
So I have that consistency
but I think that for me,
I really liked learning new techniques.
And a lot of people, if
they're seeing this one side
of skating or this one set of tricks
and don't want to branch
out because they're afraid
they won't look cool doing it or whatever,
I always wanted to try
the different techniques,
even if I stumble on them.
I knew that in the end,
it would help me be more
well-rounded and I think
that's probably what it is,
is that I just wanted to
try it and learn it all.
- Learning, learning uses creativity.
Creativity leads to thinking.
Thinking provides knowledge.
Knowledge makes you great.
- Did you have a sense that
Coldplay has reached a stage
where you just didn't
want it to be that band?
Like you wanted something else?
- No, we reached a stage where we thought,
"We can't get much bigger so
we have to try and get better."
- Yeah.
- And it's that whole thing
of quantity or quality.
We thought, "Well, we need to
practice a bit and improve"
and I was feeling bad
because I'm sure there's some
16-year-olds or kids who
say they like Coldplay
and then took some abuse
for it in the playground
and so I had a feeling
about 18 months ago,
I really would like to make
them proud by trying to improve.
- I came aboard a slogan
and I tell it to my kids
all the time, I say, "There's
no losing, only learning,
"there's on failure, only opportunities,
"and there's no problems, only solutions."
So to me, what failure
is, failure is the mother
of all success, if it
wasn't for Michael Jordan
getting cut from his
ninth-grade basketball team,
he wouldn't have became Michael Jordan.
You know, if it wasn't for, I
seen an article the other day
where they were talking about
Oprah Winfrey and how she got
fired because she wasn't
good for television.
You know, you got people like
Walt Disney who got fired,
if I'm not mistaken, from a newspaper,
saying he had no imagination.
(speaking Spanish)
These are the same people
that I got to deal with,
telling me what's not a hit record.
- [Interviewer] So what do
you tell 'em, you tell 'em?
- You know, that all they can do is learn
and come back bigger, better, stronger,
'cause all it's going to do is
lead you in the right direction.
So if you're always winning,
then you don't really
understand what it is to win,
you got to take those losses,
you got to take those hits,
it's got to be the valleys,
the peaks, the ups, the
downs, in order for you to,
when it does happen, you go, wow.
(speaking Spanish)
This is what it's all
about, and not only that,
it's never about making
it, guys, it's always about
maintaining it, that's the toughest part.
- What one quality do you think you've had
that made you and gave
you and allowed you,
pushed you, to achieve what you have?
- I think my willingness to
learn, I'm pretty relentless
when it comes to that, I
certainly knew everything
about growing up on the
street and you know,
what it took to survive on
the street corner in Dorcester
but this is a whole new world to me
so just being able to take
advantage of the things
that I've seen and the things
that I've been exposed to now
with my career, has really been.
- I continually learn from my mistakes
and other people's mistakes.
See, entrepreneurs think that,
hey, to create that billion
dollar company, or hundred
million dollar company
or even million dollar company,
you have to be really smart,
and sure, brains is part of
it, luck is a huge component,
but what I've learned over
the years is, everyone,
no matter how smart you are,
you're going to fail many times
and you're going to make mistakes,
just look at Mark Zuckerberg.
Facebook worked out,
his version of SnapChat
that was a copycat, did
not work out, right?
So there's other areas
in which Facebook failed
but Facebook overall as
a company has done great.
Just because you're smart
doesn't mean you're always
going to succeed with
everything you try or touch.
But every time you do something,
you will learn new things,
you'll make mistakes, and if
you learn from these mistakes
and avoid making 'em over and over again,
you'll actually increase
your odds of succeeding
as time goes on, and
the best way to do this
is not just to learn from your mistakes,
but it's also to learn from
the mistakes of others.
Rockefeller, Carnegie, all these people
who were entrepreneurs years
ago, in the 1800s, 1900s,
they themselves used business
principles and concepts
that are still applicable
in today's world.
Sure, we have the internet,
but the same strategies
and concepts that they used
are still applicable, right?
So learn from their mistakes,
learn what worked for them,
what didn't work for
them, why, and bring that
into what you're doing today.
- As you look back over your
life, if there's just one
thing that you could do
differently, what would it be?
- Hmm.
That's always a tough question,
I get that question asked a lot.
I'm not sure, you know, because
everything that happened
in my life produced
me, even the negatives,
even the things that I
might have failed in,
the things I made mistakes
with, they were fantastic
classrooms for me and I believe
the best thing in life to do
is not to regret and try
to change what happened,
but to interpret it properly,
maximize it and use it
to serve other people
and that's what I want to do with my past.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know whose
message had the biggest impact
on you, what was the clip that left you
wanting to make an immediate impact,
and what are some of the
challenges that you have
in staying motivated to keep learning?
Leave that in the comments
below, super curious to find out,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Shlomo Awoke,
thank you so much for
that Instagram picture
and for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
it really really really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.